how's it going bros my name is Pippa I
got a friend with me here today and my
son yes cuz this game is all about
playing with your friends mm-hmm
I feel so tall for once because you're
standing up so are you ready to laugh
what are you ready to have nightmares no
well that's too bad let's swap faces hey
you look like a troll from space ham
kids payment yeah okay that doesn't work
for me
oh god you're so ugly no offense but
Jesus Christ that is you are the ugliest
don't ever swap faces with me I'm cute
ah oh my god oh god stop don't do that
no stop I look cute on you that doesn't
know just realize how ugly I am playing
this game I'm definitely gonna have
nightmares from this
hey guys way too black for this no
phones okay oh you did not you
stink but the B word sorry again please
why me I got it for a second oh my god
oh my god
sorry my Sam breaking up with you what
has oh don't do so close no maybe it's
confused cuz it's too fake - laughs -
this little SD delay would you like a
small loan of a million dollar when you
look like that myself
you're awful to see
merrily merrily merrily mmm oh my god
today however I subscribe to my said
thank you
yeah Wow rejected on camera anything
you're on a bus no mom no you're not why
should you but then it would be normal I
feel like Julian up a bit that's
offensive
yeah they say have a golden smile oh my
god you look crazy bro fricken what if
we actually look like that that would be
so cute how these people Oh
my eyebrows ah hey hey that's pretty
good
remember I need to get to his eye for a
level no one can get on Jack's eyebrow
level oh boy wasn't this fun oh boy oh
boy did we have the best time
hey mindset why don't you leave a like
if you enjoyed this video and check why
don't you leave a like thank you for
watching this coming on I'll let you do
the brofist and three two cuz you're far
away go ahead
brofist them wait wait wait tease them a
little bit that's right
you